[Music]
I would just like hang there in the
water you keep your eyes open I'd make
lists in my mind but you'd have to be
careful not to make like too many
comprehensive complicated lists because
that also takes brain power like it's a
it's a whole it's like Zen thing
actually over 30 feet underwater so it
was free diving and then wait for Jim to
call Action did Kate come in at any time
and just say like hold my beer y'all let
me show y'all
when you're so at one with the water in
the space you know you just don't want
to be kind of going like this or
appearing to be stressed because motion
capturing you can see absolutely
everything well the vanity part of it is
you beat Tom Cruise's record I know I
know I know it's very funny people keep
telling me that Tom held his breath for
over six minutes in Mission Impossible
Rogue Nation but Kate beat his record
she credits professional training but
you think it would have been due to
another James Cameron project literally
the only similarity between Titanic and
Avatar is the that there is some water
in it Titanic actually celebrates its
25th anniversary next week and would you
believe Leo almost didn't get the part
we were leaning toward Leo but I hadn't
seen him
do anything right and he he didn't want
to read he said oh I don't read you know
I'm like well you little diva 18 years
old I'm like okay really see ya wouldn't
want to be yeah Avatar the way of water
in theaters Friday isn't just a reunion
for James and Kate reunited and it feels
so good it does it make it sound like
sunny and Cher I mean we are the Sonny
and Cher Pandora
well I want to go back to 2009. and go
back to that very first time and this is
what you told us Sam if this Avatar
thing didn't work out now would always
be the luxury of going back to Dancing
with the Stars I can always go on a you
know oil up my hips and then enjoy the
two-step I still keep my salsa skills up
[Music]